Hi everyone, I am Dr.
Matthew Heller. I am
excited to be giving
you all another lecture.
Today's lecture is going
to be in the DPR category.
So this is a DPR lecture
to prepare you for DPR
lab. A lot of what we
go through here and the
physical exam skills will
be use in the lab for DPR.
We'll also go over some
other diagnosis as well.
If you all have any
questions for me, here is my
email address. Feel free
to shoot me an email.
Again, I am going to present
the lecture regarding
the DPR. We're going to
talk about history taking.
We're going to talk about
physical exam of the spine.
So we had a long lecture,
it was pretty long.
So we had a lecture
about maybe four lectures
ago, and we talked a
lot about the spine,
cervical spine, thoracic
spine, lumbar spine,
a lot about the
differential diagnosis.
We're going to talk
more in detail about the
history taken in the physical
exam in this lecture.
We're going to talk
about subjective, right,
subjective is everything
the patient is telling
you, and objective is your
physical exam finding.
We're going to
talk about normal
versus abnormal,
we're going to talk
about the appropriate
way to document,
right, and document is
always very important,
right, you're going
to be doing it your
entire career, every
patient you ever see,
you're going to want
to make sure you
document as much as
you can, everything you
can, the most important
thing as well.
So, let's talk about
normal and abnormal,
and I'm going to show
you some documentation
as we relate it
to the OMM case,
we will talk about it later on.
So who are we? We
are the Red Wolves
and the Bears, so hello
down in Joanville,
I hope you all are
doing very well.
Hello to the Bears up in
New York, Long Island.
We haven't done this
yet, but this is a
brief, this is basically
a brief roll call.
So if you're down in
Jonesville and you're
studying in the library,
let's hear you roar.
And if you're in the New York
library, let's hear you roar.
All right, so real quick,
we will talk about Mass
Day, right, because right
now this lecture is actually
a couple of weeks before
the actual Mass Day, and
everybody, it's a pretty
exciting time. So what I am
going to do, I'm just going
to change over to my pen.
So this is an example of
Mass Day. This is how we
all have it up in New York.
So basically, you're all
going to go up and and get
an envelope at the front
of the at the front stage
you're gonna go up you're
gonna get an envelope and
then when the right time
comes the dean is gonna
announce it that it's time
to open up the envelopes
Here we go, three, two,
one!
...the day where you
find out where you're
going and what
speciality you're going.
So real quick if you
could just hit pause,
don't hit pause yet,
if you could just close
your eyes um when we hit
pause you're going to
close your eyes just
imagine yourself where
where you're going to be
on math day who you're
going to be with what
are you going to be
specializing uh where
will you be heading to
right and um and why did
you decide to go into
medicine so just hit
the pause just kind of
close your eyes and just
think about being in
that situation and I'm
opening that envelope.
I hit the pause
and we are back,
right? So we are back, but
before we get the mask day,
we do have to go through
this DPR lecture, right?
So when we get a history,
right? Whether it's the back,
the neck, the joint, very,
very common complaint is
the patient is going to say,
doc, I have pain, right?
The patient's going to
say, I have pain, right? So
that you want to do is say
where is the pain right
you're going to have the
patient locate the pain right is
the pain going to be within
the joint or is it going
to be um outside the joint
all right so if that coming
in with elbow pain or knee
pain right it's good to
know whether it's articular
or it's going to be extra
-articular right is it inside
the joint or the outside
of the joint um is it acute
versus chronic is it something
that just happened at the
basketball game today i
was running went for a
layup landed hurt my knee or
there's something that's been
going on for maybe three,
four, five months already
or even longer. You want to
know if it's inflammatory
or is it non-inflammatory.
Localized or is it
diffused, is it only
one joint or is it
multiple joints.
You also want to know is
any associated symptoms.
So a joint pain that
has a fever is a lot
different than a joint pain
that's without a fever.
So a joint pain with a fever
might suggest that maybe
there's some kind of infection
going on. where a joint
pain without a fever might
suggest, okay, maybe there
is no infection, right?
So it's something that you
want to ask, is there any
associated fevers, chills,
anything systemic
that might make
it more of a
systemic diagnosis.
So that's joint pain, and then
the next pain and back pain.
All right, you want
to know, is it a
radicular type of
pain or is it non
-radicular? We want
to know the OPQRST,
right? So we're going
to talk a little bit
more about low back
pain, right? So is the
pain midline or the
pain off the midline,
right?
Back pain could mean
a lot of things for a
lot of different people,
right? Back pain could
mean pain in the
buttock versus back pain
could be like pain in
the trapezius muscle.
So we want to know is
there any radiation
into the buttock
or is there any
radiation into the
lower extremities?
Is there any associated
numbness, tingling,
weakness, right? Is there
any parathesia, right?
um leg pain that resolve
with dress or lumbar forward
flexion right so what
position makes the pain better
what makes the pain worse
um you want to know is any
associated bowel or bladder
dysfunction right red flag
symptoms right they say
doc i'm also having some
bladder or bowel dysfunction
that i never had before i'm
having incontinence right
that could be a very very
serious different lead to
a very serious differential
diagnosis such as quarter
equine syndrome that we
talked about with impingements
on S2S4 okay so that's
something that's more emergent
or if they say doc i have
shadow anesthesia they
won't tell you i have shadow
anesthesia but you'll ask
them do you have any numbness
on the inside of your legs
upper legs and they're
going to say yeah doc i do
have it's feeling very numb
right maybe they have
urinary retention or overflow
so anything that's a red
red flag, right, we want to
make sure we roll it out
in these types of patients,
right, are they older and
now they're also having
significant weight loss,
right, again red flag symptoms,
right, so more about
red flag symptoms
we talked about
is, so the fever,
the chills,
not everything is infected,
weight loss, right,
we want to make sure,
is there any weight
loss, are they not eating,
are they having overall
weakness, if they're
having Weakness, is it
specifically from one
side or is it bilateral?
We want to find out there
are decreased or limited
movement. We want to find
out what were you able
to do before and what you
are not able to do now.
Timing, acute versus
chronic, when does it begin?
Have you ever had
this pain before?
What aggravates the pain
and what relieves the pain?
A lot of this has to do
with getting a good thorough
history taken. And all
this stuff, all this
information is going to go in
your HPI, right? So we want
to know if you're doing any
activity that you haven't
done before, right? That's
significant to know.
Maybe they're doing a
new activity. Maybe they
decided after 20 years
of not running, right,
that they are going to
come out and run a marathon
within a week, right?
So somebody that's like
that, okay, it might be
a little too much too
soon, right? So maybe
they did a little bit too
much. Now we're thinking
about an overuse injury.
So some red flag symptoms,
right? So back pain over
the age of 50 or less than
the age of 20, right? So
again, just because they
have back pain and they're
over 50, right, doesn't mean
it's automatically a red
flag, but something that
we need to keep in the back
of our mind, that it has
the potential to be a more
serious diagnosis, right,
that we need to think of.
Do they have a history of
cancer, right? Now they have
a history of cancer, now
they have severe back pain,
a longer weight
loss, right, now
you're reaping
something more serious.
Unexplained, unexplained,
key word right there,
unexplained, weight loss,
fever, or a decline in general
health, pain lasting more than
a month, or not responding
to the current treatment,
and pain that you get at
night, or increase with any
kind of resting activity.
Some more red flag symptoms,
so if they have a history
of IV drug use, IV
drug use, maybe they're
immunocompromised, they
have the presence of an
active infection or HIV,
long-term steroid use, now
we worry about bone density
being decreased, channel
anesthesia, bladder, bowel
incontinence we already
talked about and these are
something that's very alarming
and we don't want to just
dismiss it right so even
though they come in with low
back pain and they start
telling you that they have
bowel and bladder incontinence
right don't just keep
going back to the back
pain right find out there's
something that's new right
this urinating constant is
something that's new that
started along with the uh with
the back pain there's any
correlation between the two
and any neurological
symptoms or
progressive
neurological deficits
So we go through the
reviewer system, right, very,
very important, we go
through the reviewer system,
right, everybody's going to
have their favorite system
that they want to hit,
right, on the DPR, as of now,
on the self note, we require
at least three different
systems and at least two
symptoms for every system,
right, you can do more, it
doesn't hurt to do more,
right, but you want
to make sure you keep
it nice and complete
so that when you're
seeing patients, right,
and you're presenting
where you have a
nitro review system,
right? So it goes,
again, vascular,
musculoskeletal,
neural, endocrine, GU,
FUD, then for frequency,
urgency, and
dyspheria, right? We'll
learn more about
that in the fall when
you go through *******
urinary system,
and psychiatric
depression, anxiety.
Um,
so the physical exam should
be systematic, right? So
we just talked about
getting a really good HPI. I
just threw a lot of
information at you in the last
eight minutes, right? But
that's how, that's how to
get a good, thorough HPI,
right? Make sure OP, QRSC,
right? You guys all have
your own mnemonic, make
sure you know a very detailed
history about the back
pain. And I didn't
mention it, but also worth
noting, did this patient
ever have back pain before,
right? Did they ever
get imaging done in the
past, right? And these
are all questions
that the attendings are
going to ask you when
you're presenting to
them when you're on your
third-year, fourth
-year clerkship, right?
They're going to want
to know, right, this
is not part of UOP,
but they want to know,
did they ever get any
imaging before, right?
Why are they coming in
now and why did they wait
three months, right? Is
it because the pain is
getting worse? Is it
because the pain is not
improving with the self
-home treatment that they've
been doing? What were
the self-home treatment?
What were they
taking, medication?
So again, systematic,
just to make it easier
on ourselves to remember
exactly what we need to
add in the physical exam.
Everybody always forget
about inspection. That's
probably the most important
thing, is to be able to look.
Look and see if there's any
signs of trauma. Look at
the muscles. Is there any
asymmetry in the muscles
on the left side versus the
right side? Right, maybe
there's some ecchymosis or
bruising, right, maybe there
is some redness or erythema,
right, maybe there is
something, maybe there is
some kind of nodule that's
visible, whatever it might
be, right, just take a
look, right, take a look.
And then after that, we're
going to palpate, we're
going to check the range of
motion, active, right, and
passive, and then we're trend
testing, and then we will
go into special testing.
So we're going to assess the
four signs of inflammation,
right? We're going to talk
about swelling, right,
versus warmth, versus
redness, and pain tenderness,
right? If it's pain
tenderness, is it focal pain
tenderness, which might be
suggested maybe they have
some kind of injury or
trauma, or is it more diffused
tenderness? And now if they
have diffused tenderness
and warmth, right, over
any kind of, like a
thickened synovium, right,
that might suggest maybe they
have arthritis or infection,
right? So you got to
find out, is there a history
of trauma? Is there a
history of anything else
that might be infectious,
right? Then we're thinking
about difusing, difused
tendinous versus scoccal.
Again, injury versus trauma.
So examination of the
cervical spine, right?
First thing we always
want to do is take a look,
So,
by inspection, it's to
reveal that there is
sufficient cervical dosage.
Remember the curvature
that we know. You want to
observe the observation.
You want to observe
basically the position
and know how the
patient is carrying
their head in relationship
to their body.
And sometimes if their
head is rotated, not
head rotated, if the
head moves a little
bit more anterior,
sometimes the head could
be more anterior to
the rest of the body.
A lot of it has to do with
positioning of the head.
We see a lot more everybody
on their cell phone.
I always say that if you
go onto the subway and
there are ten people on
the subway in New York
City, there are ten people
on the subway, there
are going to be nine people
that are looking down
at their phone and
there's going to be one
person that's looking up
at the ceiling sleeping.
Every one of them at
some point is going
to have some kind
of neck pain because
it's not actually
the greatest posture.
So we want to make sure
that we keep maintaining
good posture, especially
if we're on our phone,
if we're on the
computer. You want to
make sure that the
computer, the top
one-third of the
screen is eye level.
Abnormal rotation.
So coming back to eye level
at the computer, you want
to make sure they have a
good ergonomic at work. And
that's part of your history
taken. What do you do for
work? Are you on the computer
all day or are you moving
around? if they are on
the computer, do they have
their ergonomic, right?
They're looking straight ahead
at the top one-third of the
screen, or do they look on
the laptop and they're
looking down the entire time.
We're going to
look for any kind
of abnormal rotation,
side bending,
and the muscle bulk
of the trapezius,
deltoid, SCM muscles
should be symmetric.
So this takes it back
when I was just in
residency. So luckily I
went to an osteopathic
program and a couple
of OMMs by one of my
colleagues and we fixed
this back up and I was
able to get right back
to seeing patients.
But this is excessive
left side bending
of the cervical
spine because it's
not supposed to
go down like that.
So we name it to what
side it is moving to.
So we do inspecting.
Next we're going to do
palpation. Palpation of
the cervical spine can be
done with the patient
sitting down or standing
up. You're going to
palpate the spinous process
with your thumbs, and
you're going to note any
kind of pain, swelling,
step-off, pain, swelling,
step-off, is there any
kind of tenderness,
anything that could
indicate there's
any kind of cervical
spine injury.
Any cervical spine that do
have spinous processes that
have a step-off or maybe
there's a distance between
the spinous process might
be significantly greater
between two vertebrae versus
another two vertebrae. If
you have any index of
suspicion, these are times where
you might say, okay, maybe
we should get an x-ray.
Maybe we should get
some kind of imaging.
You're going to
laterally palpate the
muscles on the
posterior neck. You're
going to palpate the
suboccipital area
in order if there's any
tenderness, somatic
dysfunction.
Greater occipital
nerve may be tender
and patient with
chronic headache. A lot
of patients come in
and have headaches,
right, and maybe that
headache goes into the
neck, maybe it's the
neck pain that goes into
the, turns into the
headache. Now you want to
find out on your
osteopathic exam what the,
where the pain is coming from.
All right, so after palpation,
now we're going to ask
the patient to move, right.
So we're going to go through
range of motion, right. So
we're going to go through
flexing, right? So neck
flexing, right? If you ever
tell a patient to flex their
neck, right, chances are
if they're not in the medical
field, they're not going
to know exactly what you're
talking about. So it's
good to do two things, right?
It's good to say it out
loud in layman terminology,
right? So layman terminology
is terminology where somebody
that's in the non-medical
field will know exactly
what you're talking about.
So you could say bring your
chin down to your chest.
Versus extension, you're going
to look up at the ceiling.
Rotation, look over one side,
one shoulder, and
then the other.
And then lateral bending.
That's the way the
textbooks say, but all
the textbooks would say
side bending. Either
way is fine, side
bending, lateral bending.
Either way, it's
interchangeable. You're going to
have the patient to bring
your ear to your shoulder.
And keep an eye on how they
do everything symmetric
too. So it's not the
fact that they can bring
their ear to their shoulder,
right? Is it equal on
both sides or are they
actually lifting their right
shoulder up to make it
easier for them to do it?
Meaning that they
probably have some kind of
restriction rotating side
bending rather to the right.
So most of cervical
flexion and extension
is done by the
OA joint. Most of
cervical rotation is
done by the AA joint.
So some of the textbooks
will say 50% of flexion
extension is OA, and
the other 50% is going
to be all the other
cervical vertebrae. 50
% of the cervical rotation
comes from the AA,
and the other 50% is
going to come from all
the other vertebrae
in the cervical spine.
And then lateral bending
is mostly through C2 to C7.
So active range
of motion, right?
So active range of motion,
instruct the patient.
You're going to tell them,
right? And you can
demonstrate, right? You'll be
in front of them. I always
stand in front of the
patient and I do it with
them as they do it, but
I'm also looking at them
as they do it as well.
Extensions, again,
same thing, look
up at the ceiling,
bring your chin
down to your chest,
and rotation, look over
one shoulder versus
lateral bending, bring
your ears to your shoulder,
right? But again,
make sure they're not
lifting up their shoulder
to help themselves up,
right? So a lot of my DPR
lectures are going to have
videos, right? So I ask
the patient to rotate their
head left and right,
right? Now I'm going to ask
the patient to bring her
chin down to her chest, and
I'm going to ask the patient
to look at the ceiling,
and I'm going to ask the
patient to bring her ear
to one shoulder and then
bring another ear to the
left shoulder and again
as he's doing it you're
looking for symmetric you're
looking for symmetry right
left right up down right
um and you also want to
look at the ease of the
motion as well and sometimes
if they're in pain you can
see them kind of grinning
in pain and that's all
stuff that should give you
a clue that where the
restriction is going to be uh
so we have more videos
like that coming up right
so i think especially with
the special testing, it's
going to make things a
little bit easier, I think,
right, this way it's
not just all words on
the slide. Normal range
of version, right,
there's a lot of
different textbooks
that have a lot of
different references,
right, so don't get too
caught up on it, right,
but it should be
within a certain range,
right, so flexion, right,
to be able to look down
60 to 90 degrees,
extension 70 to 90, right,
side bending should
go about 20 to 45, and
rotation is going to go
about 70 to 90 degrees.
As you want to note, if
there's any limited range
of motion, right, maybe
they have limited ROM range
of motion, right, and
that could be a number of
reasons that could be
causing it, whether it's
stiffness, they feel very
stiff, maybe it's arthritis,
maybe they're in significant
pain from trauma,
maybe it's an overuse
injury, or maybe they
have a muscle spasm,
right, kind of that
picture that I had of me
before, right, that was
from a muscle spasm
from a sort of callus.
So typically resistance
range of motion, right, now
you're going to perform
an isometric contraction,
right, so basically
you're going to have
the patient try to move
against resistance,
right, so the muscle is
going to contract, but
it's not really going
to make any changes in
length, right, so it's
going to be painful, weak,
or it could be both,
limited range of
motion, right, whether
they're stiffness, pain,
overuse, muscle spasm,
right, so these are all
stuff you want to document,
right, so after you resist
this range of motion, we
go through the neurovascular
exam, muscle strength,
right, sensation, deep
tendon reflex, right, because
we talk about the reticular
type of pain, right, so
we talk about compression
on the nerve root, right?
And when we talk about
compression on the nerve root,
right, um, we have
this chart that I just,
I had maybe like three
or four lectures ago,
right? So remember
we did this, um, C5,
uh, C6, C7, right? So,
um, in case I did anybody
misinterpreted when I talked
about the New York, uh,
you're driving in New York
on a highway and, um, and
somebody cut you off and you
cut somebody else off right
um so we don't we don't
so i say that new yorkers
right they may give you the
finger right and that'll
be your c7 and then as
they're giving you the finger
right they're giving this
you out the window right so
when they give you the uh
the middle finger out the
window in order to do that
they are going to have to
extend their elbow right
they're going to have
to extend their elbow
and they're going to have
to flex their wrist all
right so when i mentioned
that in the last
lecture we don't do that
but But there are other
people in New York, and
if you cut them off,
then don't be bothered by
it. Just keep going and
try not to do it again.
So that's C7, and that
is your tricep reflex.
So C6, C5, and just know that
they're all related to sensory,
motor,
and reflex. But by now,
you probably all have this
memorized because it's
very important to know.
Cervical spine
examination, limits sign.
So this is also known
as barber's chair
phenomenon, so basically
the patient is going to be
sitting down on the table
and they're going to
attempt to actively
hold their head upright.
The patient is going to
feel an electric shock
sensation that goes down the
spine, arm or the leg. So
again, the patient is going
to attempt to actively
hold their head upright,
and that's going to create
a shock sensation, this is
all indicated potentially
for spinal stenosis,
but you still want to
rule out other significant,
more serious diagnosis,
multiple chlorosis, ALS, or
Arnold C.R.A. malformation.
Axial compression test,
so you're standing
behind the patient, you're
going to perform the
test one time, because
if you keep doing it,
eventually it's going
to hurt the patient.
We don't want to hurt
the patient, so we'll
just do this one test,
just make sure when you're
doing it, you have it
in the right position.
All right, so Gabiner places
both hands on top of the
patient's head, and they're
going to provoke a downward
force with both hands,
so both hands right here
is going to be axial
compression. It's going to be
going down. So, axial compression
is going to be significant
for a cervical nerve
impingement. Usually, they're
going to have pain or
neurological symptoms of the
cervical spine and or upper
extremity to reproduce.
So, that's going to
reproduce the pain.
So, opposite of axial
compression, we are
going to have the
foraminal distraction test.
So, here he's put one hand
underneath the patient's
chin and the other
hand is on the occiput.
So here's the occiput,
here is the chin, and he's
going to be lifting,
and that force going up,
right? So this is positive,
right, if when he's
lifting up and the pain
goes away or the pain is
reduced, right? So again,
a positive test, meaning
the pain and or neurological
symptoms of the cervical
spine and or upper
extremities are reduced,
right? Are reduced, right?
So that's a positive test
if there's a reduction in
the pain with traction,
right? what that's doing
is because that's going
to alleviate the cervical
nerve impingement.
So again, that would
be a positive test if
the pain is reduced,
if there's no change,
then you could say that
it's a negative test.
One of the more common tests,
very common, we see this a lot,
Spirling test. Spirling
is looking for a
foraminal compression
on the nerve root.
So simply, what we are going
to do, again, foraminal
compressing on the nerve
root, so what we're going to
do, we're going to place one
hand on top of the head, of
the patient's head, and
then on the other hand, he's
going to be on the affected
side, so if he's complaining
of left-sided pain on the
neck, so what he is going
to do, he's going to side
bend and rotate the neck
towards the side of the pain,
which is to the left side.
He's going to add a little
bit of extension, and
then he's going to put
a downward force. But
just keep in mind that if
he does this and sees in
pain before he even gets
to the downward force,
you don't have to do
the downward force,
because if they're
telling you they're in
pain, you don't want
to put them through any
more pain than what
they're experiencing.
So if they have a pain
radiating down into the arm
when the head is rotated, so
sometimes if you just rotate
the head to the left and
side bend to the left, if
they already have the pain
and it's radiating down into
the arm, you can assume
that they have a strepical
radiculopathy. If they
don't have the pain,
then you can always
add the extension.
So here we are going to
add the extension, and then
the downward force
compression, and that's going
to be compression on the
nerve root, and that's going
to tell you that there is
cervical radiculopathy.
So some injuries, most
common cervical injuries,
a lot of this we
already talked about, so
I don't want to talk
too much about it. It's
just to know that the
most common is going to
be the cervical strain
or the cervical sprain.
So this is usually self
-limiting, right, usually
you have to give it
time to heal, you have
to give it time with rest,
ice, anti-inflammatory,
and a very gradual
return to activity.
OMM is very effective,
right, reducing tendinitis,
reducing pain, reducing
muscle hypotonicity.
Traumatic dysfunction is
going to develop, right,
you may get straightening
of the cervical spine,
right, we talked about
that, straightening of
the cervical spine, they
may get some headaches,
cephalosia, fingers,
burners, right, that results
from ipsilateral,
meaning on the same side,
compression or contralateral
traction to your
cervical plexus, and the
pain is going to be a
significant pain that
travels down the nerve root.
We talked about
osteoarthritis, right,
so a common condition
where multiple
joints in the vertebra
bone component,
right, they get classic
changes, and so this
is where we talked about
like the osteophyte
formation, right,
bone calcification,
right, that's going to
lead to osteoarthritis,
and then we have degenerative
disc disease, right,
remember we talked about
DDD, you throw that on
the other selector,
right? Degenerative disc
disease, wearing chair
phenomenon that occurs when
the, across the disc
vertebrae interface, and
basically it happens to us
when we get older, right?
Inherent loss of water,
right? The disc becomes,
it begins to degenerate.
Some more urgent things
to mention, right?
Fractures, right? not good, not
a good thing,
cervical fracture.
Moderate forces are at
play, pain, and dysfunction
are disproportionate to
the physical finding.
So they're yelling, they're
13 out of 10 pain, but the
physical finding doesn't
support it. You always want
to make sure that you rule
out any kind of fracture.
Maybe they have a
pinpoint tenderness,
maybe they have
neurological findings.
So that's something we
rule out. We want to make
sure we stabilize the
head. And herniated discs,
right, we're talking
about disherniation,
infection,
inflammatory condition,
malignancy, right, myelopathy.
Again, myelopathy is due
to an injury to the spinal
cord and not the nerve
root, right? Nerve root is
radiculopathy, spinal cord
compression is myelopathy,
right? And these are the patients
that's going to present
with ataxia, bowel, bladder,
incontinence, right? Shadow
anesthesia. Not chattel
anesthesia, but bowel,
bladder, incontinence, ataxia.
Significant upper nerve,
upper neuron finding,
they're going to have
the hypereflexia.
So thoracic outlet syndrome,
and more vascular emergency
that needs to be ruled out.
So we use our NEXUS
criteria. right, so NEXIS
criteria is a criteria that
we use to determine whether
the cervical spine needs
imaging or if you can
avoid imaging in the
appropriate patient, right. So
it's a very well validated
clinical decision aid,
right. So when you are on
the football field or you're
in the ring and somebody
has an injury to the
head, right, you want to
be able to safely rule out
a cervical spine injury.
So if you can't rule out
a cervical spine injury,
you have to assume that
they have a neck injury.
So the five criteria that
we're going to talk about,
if none of them are present,
right, the C-spine can
be cleared clinically,
right? So they have to
have no neurological
deficit, no spinal
tenderness, right, no
ulcerative mental
status, no intoxication,
right, they can't be
altered mental status,
and they can't have any
distraction or painful
injury. If they don't
have any of these five
criteria, then you can
rule out a suit spine,
and you don't have to worry
about imaging, you can
monitor. But if they have any
one of these, that's going
to change the whole game
plan. So if they have any
of these, neurological
deficits, they have fine
tenderness, altered mental status,
right, they're unconscious,
right, intoxicated, they
have, when we talk about
distracting pain injuries,
not that you get distracted
by another injury, maybe
they have a cut on their
forehead or whatever it
might be, but we're talking
about a significant painful
injury, right, we're
talking about a broken femur,
right, a broken femur is
going to distract the
patient from their neck pain,
right, because they have so
much pain in their femur.
so um when a fighter get
hit they get knocked in the
head right and now they
uh they're unconscious but
the fighter keeps punching
them in the head they take
another couple more blows
and they land on the ground
they're unconscious and
their head is bouncing off
the ground a couple of
times and if i go in there
and the guy and the fighter
is not awake right and
he's also his mental status
or he has positive loss of
consciousness right i also
assume that he has the
next injury so what I'll do
is I'll wait for the EMS,
right, and they're going
to come over, they're
going to put a collar
on him, they're going to
put him on a backboard,
and they are going to
take him out by ambulance,
right, if he's unconscious,
right, but we have
to assume that he has
a neck injury, and that's
next to his criteria.
But if he begins to wake
up, now I'm going to put
my, I'm going to, I'm
going to have him still
laying down, I'm going
to palpate, palpate the
neck, I want to make sure
there's no spine tenderness,
right, and I'm going to
ask him, are you having
any pain, I'm going
an active event, any
neurological symptoms,
right, because I want to make
sure I can safely rule out
any kind of spine injury
before I help him get
back up, right, so, um,
so again, right, you
want to just palpate the
spine, right, maybe you
can have him move their
heads to the side, left
and right, and that's part
of the neck trachea we're
going to talk about,
right, so the Canadian C-spine,
right, this is a
little bit more, um,
more advanced, not advanced
but this is a little bit
more um a little more
complicated i guess uh than
the nexus criteria. The
nexus criteria they just give
you the fine thing if they
have any one of them then
you put a call on them and
you and you probably have
to and you get imaging if
you're not in the hospital
you have to transfer over
to the hospital right when
we talk about the canadian
c-spine this is used in
the alert and stable trauma
patients where the c-spine
might be a concern right
and And what this does is
they kind of have risk
factors, right? So some of
the risk factors that they
may have is that they're
over the age of 65, right?
They're over the age of 65,
right? Maybe they have some
kind of dangerous mechanism
or they have any numbness
in their extremities.
And all these are going
to be high risk factors
where you're going to
want to get imaging done.
If the patient
doesn't have any risk
factors and they have
low risk factors,
right? So if they have
any low-risk factors,
maybe they fall from
a sitting position,
maybe they're in
like a low-velocity
motor vehicle accident, MVA.
If they have any low-risk
factors, then you would
want to have the patient be
able to rotate their head
45 degrees to the right
and 45 degrees to the left.
This is tough to memorize
the whole thing, so I
wouldn't expect you all to
memorize the whole thing. But
this is something that
you'll see in the ER, they
have this, if they do go by
the Canadian C-spine rule,
they're going to
have this up in the
ER, you'll be able
to look at it.
And the more you look
at it, the more it's
going to become, you're
going to know exactly
what you're looking
for in the criteria.
So we get to the thoracic
spine, now we do cervical,
now we're going to get
back to thoracic spine.
We're going to talk about
inspection. You're going
to, just like every other
exam, you begin looking
at the patient, right?
And just to make it not
so awkward when you're
looking, right, there's nothing
wrong saying I am
looking at your back. I'm
looking for any muscle
abnormality. I'm looking for
any obvious signs of
deformity, muscle imbalance,
any bone abnormality,
right? I'm looking at
the skin condition. I'm
looking for symmetry
or asymmetry. I'm
looking at the curvature,
right? there's nothing wrong
saying it out loud this
way the patient knows
exactly what you're saying,
what you're doing, and
it's going to help you when
you document. If you say
there's no other thema,
there's no echemosis, now
when you go to write your
note, it makes it so much
easier because you said
it out loud, right, you
know you can document
because you actually were
looking for those findings.
Palpation, right, on skin,
right, thoracic, lumbar
junction, right, usually
there's some kind of,
there can be a significant
finding. You want to
palpate the thoracic and
the lumbar spine, palpate
the paraspinal, palpate
the spinal trusses, work
your way down. You're
going to be using your
thumb as you're going down.
Evaluate with the skin
drag test and the erythema
test, very important test.
We went over this pretty
detailed in OMM lab, but you
do a skin drag test. It's
going to tell you a lot
of information about the
condition, whether it's
chronic, whether it's acute,
whether it's something
going on on the right side,
left side, and what area
of the spine is going on.
Again, we talk about range
of motion, right? Range
of motion, right? Not
only can they do the
range of motion, right?
But do they have any pain
or tenderness with these
range of motions, right?
Especially if they have any
kind of pain that radiates
into the legs, right?
This is going to warrant a
neurological testing later
on. So you want to make sure
you keep an eye at that
pain radiating into the legs
and you're going to want to
keep an eye and then maybe
do a full neurological test
of the lower extremity.
So we're going to
start with flexing. So
flexing, you can easily
say to the patient,
bend forward and try
to touch your toes.
Note the symmetry
of the movement.
Are they having any pain?
The patient's going to
flexing over here. So
when the patient is
going to flexion. This is
going to be, you're
going to be able to check
out the psoas muscles,
you're going to the
hip flexors, so you
have the psoas muscles.
And then you're going to
go into neck, not neck,
but you're going to go
into back extensions.
So you're going to have
the patient bend backwards.
So you're going to have the
patient bend back as far
as possible, and you're going
to place your hand on the
PSIS with the fingers
pointing towards the midline.
This is all going to
be on the DPR handout.
And then the next is going
to be rotations. This
is all active. Have the
patient actively rotate.
Have the patient, you can tell
them rotate from side to side.
And then you're going
to have the patient
lateral bending, side
bending. You're going to
have the patient bend to
the side of the waist.
Any decrease in spinal
mobility. We talked about some
of the diagnosis earlier.
We talked about OA, we
talked about ankylosing
spondylitis, right, these are
all stuff to keep in mind
as potential differential,
um,
range of motion, flexion,
right, very easily done,
right, have the patient
bend down as far as they
can go, try to touch
the ground if they can,
right, and then they're
going to come back up, and
you're going to ask them,
do you have any pain
while you went down, um,
and then next is going to
be extension, right, so
again, extension, right?
Very, very important to do
extension because you're
going to put more pressure
on the posterior aspect
of the spine. And we talked
about some differential
diagnosis where they may
have more pain on extension,
right? Just as
spondylolysis, right? Now
they're putting more
pressure on the part
intra-articularis when
they're leaning back.
Next is going to be
rotation, right? So, this is
passively, you're going
to put one hand on the
hip, one hand on top of
the shoulder, and you're
going to rotate them from
one side to the next.
And then our side bending
is going to be active.
So active side bending.
We talked about,
again, if they have
neck pain or they
have back pain, then
you need to do the
neurological testing.
So remember what we
said about L4? L4,
right, kick the door, right,
so L4, kick the door,
there's nothing for L5, and
then S1 is the Achilles tendon,
right, muscle strength,
right, so you're
going to have ankle
dorsiflexion at L4,
right, great show,
dorsiflexion at L5, and plantar
flexion at S1, and then the
sensory, medial, L4, dorsal,
L5, lateral, S1, we're
gonna do some of the tasks
we're gonna go through,
alright, so some of them are
pretty very very straightforward,
right, so it's good
to know if you have any,
if you have any suspicion
for certain diagnosis,
right, these are all tasks
that you can easily do
that's going to help you out,
right, the first task is
the at a scapular elevation,
right? So basically
you're going
to ask the patient to lift up,
right? If, let's say for
example, she does have
pain or weakness on
this left side, right?
Then next thing you can
do is maybe you can say
to the patient, can you
side bend or can you
lateral bend your head
to your left shoulder,
right?
You're going to
ask her to lateral
bend and if there's
weakness there,
right, then you can also
consider the fact that
maybe it's not just a muscle
injury, but maybe it's
more of a nerve injury.
And what nerve did we
talk about where they may
have a nerve injury, that
could be cranial nerve
number 11, right, the spinal
accessory nerve, because
you're testing for the
trapezius when you're
lifting up, right, you're
testing the SCM as your
side bending to the side.
Endonitis, again,
trapezius, or the
levator scapulae, or
you might have cranial
nerve damage at the
spinal accessory,
right, so again, arm dressing
on the side, have the
patient shrug their
shoulders up again to resist
them, and they're going
to have pain or weakness.
Winging of the scapula,
right, winging of
the scapula, the patient
pushes against the
wall with both hands,
with their feet farther
away from the walls
and the shoulders,
right, and you're going to note
that there's scapular winging,
right, or weakness
during the maneuver,
right, very, very
commonly tested,
right, all over. You
can express, say,
serratus anterior weakness,
right, but there's
also other muscles
that can also generate
winging from the
scapula, right, keep in
mind lateral winging
can also be caused by
trapezius and rhomboid
paralysis or weakness.
So again, scapular
winging, protracting,
right, you can see the It's
asymmetric on one
side versus the other.
The next test we're going to
talk about is abstin test.
So abstin, the patient
is going to palpate the
radio pulse. So that radio
pulse is right there.
The patient is going to
rotate their head toward
the test's arm. So she's
going to rotate her
head to the left, and
she's going to tilt her
head backwards. So her
head is going to go
backwards, and she's going
to rotate to the left.
And the examiner is going
to abduct and extend
the arm. So he's abducting
the arm, bringing
the arm away and bringing
it into extension.
The patient has to inhale
and turn the head toward
the affected side. So she's
going to inhale, turn her
head, and that radial
pulse is going to diminish.
That's going to
diminish, and that could
be indicative of
thoracic outlet syndrome,
usually related to the
scalen musculature.
So we talked about the
impingements of the
artery, the subclavian
artery in particular,
but there could be other
causes of a somatic
outlet syndrome that
we need to consider.
We're going to ask
and test. Then we
also have some
other related to the
scalene. It could be
related to the rib.
We're going to go over
atom testing. right?
Atom testing is a test
to screen for scoliosis.
So the patient is
standing, they're going
to have their
patient bend forward
and you're looking
at the side from one,
from one side of the rib
cage to the other side,
right? So you're going
to, if there's the
presence of a unilateral
rib cage or rib hump,
then it's going to mean that
they probably have some kind of
scoliosis.
So let's say that the
scoliosis is like this.
So the concavity is on
the left side. What you're
going to notice is that
the rib hump is to the
right because the vertebra
is rotating to the right.
Just be careful, a lot
of test questions like to
say the spinous process
is going to be going to
the left. So when we have
the spinous process, So
when we have that
spinous process, when
that's going to the
left, we can say that
whatever vertebra
that is, that's
going to be rotating
to the right.
So the spinous process
is moving to the left,
and the vertebra is
rotating to the right.
So the spinous process
is going towards the
concavity, and the
vertebrae is going to be
curving to the right
side, and that's
why you get that little
hump right there.
Test, ****** test, very simple.
One leg up, maybe not
simple for everybody, but if
they can't tolerate the test,
you don't have to do the
test, right? But if they
can, right, you can have
the patient stand on one
leg, lift up the other leg,
right? And that's going to
create a hyperextension,
right?
Hyperextension, right?
Positive test is going
to be indicated by pain
in the lower back. This
stresses out the
posterior elements of the
spine, right? Posterior
elements of the spine.
And that could be indicated
of what we mentioned
before, is you're putting
more pressure on the pars
interarticularis, right? If
there's a stress fracture or
if there's a fracture or
if there's any pathology,
right? We worry about, we
worry about fondolelysis.
The straight leg test,
right? Another test done
in OMM lab, right? but
we're going to review
over this again because
it's very important,
very commonly used,
right? Patients do pines.
They relax their legs.
We do the work. We're
going to lift the leg
with the knee extended,
raised off the table, right?
The bilateral exam, we
do the side that's not
hurting first. If they have
a radicular pain coming
from the back and it goes
through the sciatic nerve
distribution and it goes below
the knee, we worry about
nerve root impingement.
So again, straight leg
test, usually, so yeah,
they're going to have a
reproducible pain that's
going down the posterior
aspect of the leg,
usually it's about maybe
30, 40, 50 60 70 degrees
70 degrees um so 30 to
70 degrees um further
support um straight
leg test is um brogaard
test all right so brogaard
is very very similar
bring the leg up
whoop that causes pain
and that causes pain
again all right so
So you're going to
bring the patient up,
dorsiflexion of the foot,
L5 portion of the scatastic
nerves will be stressing
leading to pain.
Again, that's going to be
indicated of nerve root
impingement, pain that
radiates below the knee.
Wells opposite straight
leg raising, right, so
patient raises, so there's
active patients who
are doing the work, and
they're going to raise
their straight leg on
the uninvolved side. It's
provocative if pain is
experienced on the side
opposite that being
tested or raised rather.
The test is positive for
a possible face occupying
lesion if the pain occurs
on the opposite side.
So it's raised if the
uninvolved leg and
pain on the opposite
side is developing.
Hoover's test, again,
Hoover's test is a test for
potential for maliggering
or a patient possibly
trying to, not giving enough
effort into the exam, maybe
they have other goals,
so they're seeking secondary
gain potentially again
this is just one test you
don't just out of many
right you don't just do the
one test and just say that
the patient is malignant
right um you have to take
everything else that
goes into the um into the
history taking the whole
physical exam right but this
one test is just one test
out of many that you're
going to be doing and
basically what happened is if
they're really trying you're
going to act the patient
let's say it's the left
leg that is injured,
you're going to
ask the pacing to
lift the left leg
off the table.
If they're lifting and
they're trying as hard as they
can, they're going to create
a reciprocal force that
is going down on this left
foot, this left ankle.
So if they're trying to
get this leg up and they're
really trying, what's going
to happen is they're going
to really push down on this
side. So you're going to
feel pressure going down and
that's usually a negative
finding because we know
that they're really trying,
they're giving a good effort
by trying to bring that
leg up. If they say, doc,
I can't get my left leg
up and they're making no
motion over here, right,
there's no contralateral
force going down, then that's
the potential that it could
be a positive test. Again,
one test out of many in the
whole history, right, so
you don't want to say 100
% the patient's malignant,
but it's something to keep
in the back of your mind.
uh some differential
diagnosis and i'm not going
to go through them all
because we went through
them already uh lumbar
strain lumbar strain
right a herniated disc
right final stenosis right
you're going to have a
diculopathy pain uh final
stenosis uh you're going
to have spondylolysis
spondylolysis spondylolysis
right try saying
that three times over
and over again and
we're going to have
compression fracture.
More serious etiology,
quarter esquina syndrome,
again, this is stuff
that we don't want to
miss. So they have bowel
or bladder incontinence,
they have urinary
retention, they have
progressive motor or
sensory loss, you do an
exam, they have saddle
anesthesia, weakness,
major motor weakness,
right,
something to consider,
cauda squina, cancer, right,
again, we don't want to
miss it, so they have
unexplained weight loss, they
have other history of cancer,
right, they have vertebral
tenderness, again,
fracture can also be vertebral
tenderness, right, they
could have significant
trauma that's related to the
AIDS, right, so they could
be involved in a high
velocity car accident,
maybe they have a history of
osteoporosis, maybe they have
a history of steroid use.
And then infection.
Severe pain, maybe they
had lumbar spine surgery in
the past and now they're
having potential for
infection and maybe they have
a history of IV drug use.
And maybe they
have fever on their
history taken, they have fever.
Or they have other
kinds of infection
going on. This
is stuff where we
don't want to miss
these etiologists.
So we are doing good on
time. We're almost done. I
just got a quick case
because with the DPR lab,
we want to give a case. So
a patient comes in, a 77
-year-old, and their chief
complaint is back pain.
So the patient
came in. This is a
real patient. See,
it's a real case.
Very, very real case.
And it's one of many,
many cases that we see
using the osteopathic
manipulative medicine,
right, OMM, OMT, right.
If you're a third year,
just make sure, and
you're virtuating
with me at the clinic,
right, I always ask the
third year right in front
of the patient. Well, I
usually ask the patient, I'm
like, do you have any
further questions about what
OMM is, right, and then
if they say yes, then I
always direct it right
to the third year medical
student so make sure you have
a good definition in your
head That's exactly how
you're going to explain
it to a person that might
not be familiar with OMM.
But that's a side
note, going back to the
case, 77-year-old male
coming to the clinic
for chronic upper
and lower back pain,
pain going on for about
10 years, he has a history
of Parkinson's, and I
act the patient and point
to the pain, and he
points to the lower back
on both sides, and he
said the pain is about a 3
-4 on a pain scale, it's
a dull, achy pain and
there's no radiation to
the pain so I hit my OPQRT.
Pain is worse when he
prolongs standing and
walking and it gets
better when he's resting.
The work up so far is that
he's done multiple ortho
evaluations. He had
epidurals in the past. He
has physical therapy. I
want to know what have you
done before. I want to
know what kind of imaging
you've done before. He had
a lumbar, sacral, spine
x-rays, or moderate
degenerative disc narrowing,
and small central disc,
so he had an MRI rather,
disc herniations, and mostly
in the lower lumbar reasons.
So MRI shows that there's
some self-degenerative
disc disease and small
central disc herniations.
So review system, no
weight loss or weight gain.
He does have difficult
sleeping, the pain kind
of keeps him up at night,
head, eye, There's no
throat, right, no throat
pain, changes in vision.
Cardio, there's no chest
pain, palpapation, pulmonary,
no shortness of breath,
no cough, GI, no belly
pain, no ulcer, vomiting,
diarrhea, constipation,
neurology, no headache,
numbness, or tingling,
right. There's no urinary,
there's no bowel or bladder
incontinence, there's no
shadow anesthesia. Again,
review your system, right,
you want to make sure
that it's something to
bring up. And then we go
through allergies, right.
So every one of your ******
notes should have something
similar to this, right?
So allergies, if they
say they have an allergy
to penicillin, your
very next question
should be what kind of
reaction do you get?
Medications, when I'm
listing medications, they're
dosing, and how often
they're taking it, right?
And if they're taking a
PRN, Claritin is taking
PRNs, right? They're
taking it for allergies,
right? And Lodipine is
taking it for blood pressure,
right? So their past
medical history should have
blood pressure, right? and
it should have Parkinson's.
Surgical history, appendectomy.
Family history, I
just did the mother
and father, but in
the DPR lab, make
sure you get... I
usually get all the...
You want to get out of
your three generations.
You want to get the parents,
the siblings, and if
they have any kids, any
differential diagnosis.
Are they deceased or are they
alive? Very important
to document.
Social history, retired
accountant. limited exercise,
secondary to pain, and
healthcare maintenance,
one with the last
colonoscopy, and vaccinations,
and any other
healthcare screening.
Physical exam, vital
signs, as listed,
general, head,
extremities, neurological,
basically he had
a normal mental
status with hypophonic
and tachypneic.
So normal mental status, he
was speaking with hypophonic
and tachypneic. So motor
strength is limited by
increased tone bilateral, and
he had pronounced camptoformia.
So what is camptoformia?
And also, how is he walking,
right? Is he walking
with a walker, right? Is
he walking with a cane,
right? Is he ambulatory in
pain, right? Is he limping,
right? He also has walking
with a camptoacormia. So
what is camptoacormia? So
this is what a camptoacormia
is. It's a severe significant
flexion of the spine
and usually this can also
be referred to as bent
spine syndrome, BSS,
right? Where the patient
appears in a standing
position, right, and they
have significant abnormal
flexion of the trunk.
All right, so physical exam,
again, musculoskeletal,
thoracic spine, head
forward and rounded
shoulder posture. There's no
vertebral spine tenderness,
no muscle spasm present
bilaterally, right,
there's an increased
thoracolumbar spine flexion,
right,
range of motion extremely
limited in all directions.
So, he came in to try some
OMM and on the osteopathic
structural exam, you
always want to begin at
the different body parts
when you're diagnosing and
when you're treating and
when you're documenting.
So we started off at
the cranial, so he
has subaccipital
hypotonicity, we talked
about the OA and
how he treated it.
Every documentation
you do for OMM,
you always have to
have a diagnosis.
You have to have the severity,
you have to have the
treatment that you
did, and you have to
have the response.
Because later on, when
you all learn how to
build, you're going to
learn how to build based
on how many body parts
that you're treating,
right? So we talked about
the cranial cervical,
so again, cervical,
right, definitely
the hypotonicity of
the upper trap. We
talked about C4, we
were able to localize,
severity was pretty
severe, right,
we did some FPR,
mild fascia release,
and some thoracic, right, we
treated the lumbar, right,
the lumbar, some muscle
spasm, activated the L1-L3,
right, some muscle spasm
in the thoracic spine
as well, right, so we
talked about the treatment,
and the upper extremity,
fascial restriction
in the bilateral
shoulders, right, so modify
Spencer's technique
because, again, he was 78.
He had difficulty
rotating onto the side, so
we figured we could
try it with him in the
supine position, right,
and I would try to
do some of our direct
small fascial release.
So on the assessment,
right, when I
wrote my note and I
wrote my assessment,
right, so he had back
pain, but that's, we're
in the medical field.
That's not enough.
right, we have to say why
does he have back pain,
right, that's our job
is to figure out why
and any treatment that
might be, that might help,
right, so multi-bacterial,
right, so there's a
lot of things that's causing
his back pain, whether
it's the degenerative disc
disease, the herniated
disc, the spondylosis,
the arthritis changes,
multiple somatic dysfunction,
right, he has the history
of Parkinson's disease,
he has the canphyromia,
right, that could be related
to the Parkinson's disease
probably is, and that
whole thing is out of the
assessment and then we come
up with a plan, right? So
you all are just learning
how to write the plan now,
right? So you want to say,
what did you do for the
patient in the office and
what is the plan and when are
they going to follow up,
right? You always want to
make sure when the patient
is following up, when you
need to see them again
and maybe you're not doing
something now, but you might
do something in the future,
right? In that case, you
consider getting imaging if
the pain doesn't get better,
if the pain gets worse
and i write this in here
because if i don't see the
patient next time because
maybe i'm not there and
somebody else see the patient
they look at my note and
they know exactly what was
in my thought process so we
talked about omam hydration
eating healthy applying
heat right especially for
the chronic pain right the
acute pain i like to use
ice right anti-inflammatory
back exercises range
of motion physical
therapy right work
on balance and
tylenol motrin as
needed for the pain.
The patient on the second
visit followed up feeling
better and one thing he
did notice that was pretty
significant he was able to
fully lift his back to an
upright position which is
something that he hasn't been
able to do for a very
very very long time and so
within the second visit he
was pretty happy and then
on a third visit he went
from being happy to being
very happy with the treatment.
He was able to stand
outside for the first time
and be able to stand tall,
things that we'll take and
be able to look at the sky,
right? Because when you're
in Camp Del Cormier,
right, you're just looking
down the entire time, right?
So he was able to do
something that we all take for
granted, right? He was able
to go outside, be able to
lift his back up, be able
to look up into the sky,
and that was something
that he was not able to do
prior, right? So definitely
a significant improvement.
So to summarize, right, I
know I went maybe a couple
minutes over. I do apologize
again, but I put a lot of
videos in there, I hope the
video helps you all out.
We do have, I do have
one more lecture for you
coming up, right, and
that's going to be the
another, actually I
have two more great
lectures, actually the
next lecture is going to
be really, really good,
because that is, I
can't tell you what it
is, you're going to have
to find out by watching
the next lectures,
right, and something definitely
you should be looking
forward to, and I do use
two of the past medical
students to help me out one
of them is now in a urology
residency and I'm giving
way too much information so
I'll let you I'll let you
look forward to that next DPR
lecture but the summary
slide now and then there's
one more lecture so I have
two more lectures for you
all coming up so the summary
slide history taken physical
exam. We talked about the
subjective, objective,
normal, abnormal, how to
document normal versus
abnormal finding. We talked
a lot about special testing.
And special testing,
very important to know,
and incorporating of
OMM in the case study.
So these are the references.
A lot of them are on the
slide. Definitely leave
feedback. Let me know if
you have any questions,
comments, concerns, Do you
have any suggestions for me
to make the lectures
better? I always want to try
better because I know as a
medical student, you guys
are getting so many lectures,
so I try to make it a
little bit of entertaining.
It may go a few minutes
late, but I hope that you
can all look forward to
what you have coming up,
a lot of great stuff
coming up with second year,
third year, being on
clinical rotation, master's,
graduation, all going to
be here within three years.
So thank you all for watching,
if you have any questions
please let me know,
otherwise have a great day.